women I think you can actually prevent a  woman from cheating but I don't think  you can prevent a man from cheating  I think a man can be very happy and  satisfied and still step out but I think  with a woman the moment she feels some  neglect that's when her things are  heightened when she's not neglected  she's tends to be more loyal neglect  leads to I think we're woman cheats  because they think they can do better  but I think neglect determines whether  they think they can do better I think a  man that's not neglecting you you think  okay I'm upset but when he starts  neglecting you you think I can do better  I just I think you're either that guy to  her you're not